and then one day i was sitting at my
home and drinking a glass of a
fine liquor and looking at the website
and seeing the book a demo
button i was thinking to myself i
would never click this button i would
never book a demo to my own company
why would i do this i would never buy
something like that
and then i knew something had to be done
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel at stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm honored to be joined by
shimon thortz the ceo and co-founder of
the three io
shimon established and managed the
software engineering infrastructure
department for 400 engineers at iron
souls
also as an aws community hero shimon
runs the largest aws
user group worldwide and as an avid
speaker at conferences
today shimon is the ceo and co-founder
at datri
an automated policy enforcement solution
for kubernetes
the cli tool prevents kubernetes to
misconfigurations
by ensuring the manifests and helm
charts follow best practices
as well as your organization's policies
welcome to 20 minute leaders hey thank
you so much for having me
this is the second time that i that i'm
having the first time was on zoom during
covet
and now i get to be in your beautiful
offices and which unfortunately you
can't see too much of with these walls
but but it's
but behind there there's a group of
amazing engineers and amazing people
that are working
on building this really awesome product
and while last time we talked about
infrastructure code is infrastructure we
talked about
the world of devops there's going to be
a really interesting story to hear this
time because you've had a lot of
different things happening over this
last
year since we had our last episode and i
can't wait to learn more about shimon
and a lot more about the conviction
that you came in with that i think i as
a young entrepreneur and many young
entrepreneurs can learn so much from
so shimon in a few words about the three
and then take us a little bit through
your covert journey that you had
wow so it's really fun to be here thank
you very much and we're really honored
to have you here with us
it's much better than last night
using zoom um in a few words what we do
is we prevent misconfigurations from
ever reaching production
in kubernetes based environments
so basically you have developers that
are writing code making changes working
on different kubernetes manifests helm
templates
and then they're shipping them into
production and many times you can
make mistakes you can forget to put in a
memory limit the liveness probe and so
on
and then this can affect your production
so what we do is we apply
automated tests that run every time that
there is a
code change made by a developer and if
he or she makes a mistake and forget
some policy
we prevent this change from reaching
production
and causing great issues now this is not
something that
necessarily would have been relevant six
or seven years ago and so
what what happened in the world of
computing and cloud that that enables
this problem to be so significant today
and that wasn't before yeah so i think
that the main changes that happen
is our shift into developer autonomy
you know breaking up the the teams and
making it
possible for anyone to deploy into
production
and before those days we used to have
the ops teams they would take everything
into production and we had the
development teams who would just write
the code and maybe qa teams
that would test it now in the devops
world it's all
meshed together and together with that
the cloud
and the cloud native technologies like
that came from the cloud native
foundation like kubernetes
which is actually i call it an
abstraction layer
and on top of all infrastructure
it can be amazon google azure no matter
what
you can use kubernetes in order to
actually operate
your data center and this is a common
language common api that everyone uses
now in the world in order to do so
because the world started shifting into
a very fragmented place
where you would have the amazon apis and
the google apis and azure apis and so on
so now everything is being brought back
together using the cloud native
foundation
amazing and so you're working in that
domain and you're
understanding that the autonomy of
developers is introducing
different problems to the world that
didn't exist six or seven years ago so
with all the goodness
that we have from the autonomy now
there's different
different prone to airness and and this
is where the treat comes in and it's
really relevant to any
any uh company that is living in the
cloud or moving to the cloud which is
everybody and so take me back
a year or a little bit more than a year
you're in y combinator last time i was
here you were doing something a little
bit different a little bit more general
tell me a little bit about the journey
that you took on yourself to understand
really what you want to be doing
okay so a lot of happened as you know in
the coveted world is
obviously changed a lot just to
refresh your mind you know before i
started the tree i was a
head of an engineering department at
iron source and which is a great company
they're now
ipoing for 10 billion dollars um
so despite you being heavily seen
and what happened there is i was leading
the infrastructure division
and we had 400 engineers and one day an
engineer made a mistake
we all make mistakes like mistakes you
make mistakes and we post more to it and
we found the problem
but then we had no way of propagating
these development standards to the
entire company
we started sending emails and trying to
do you know conferences but
it wasn't scalable and this what
actually prompted me and my co-founder
er
to quit their jobs and to do it in an
automated way that
is seamlessly integrated within the
development workflow
so every time a developer makes a code
change like when you write a word
document
you have the small spell checker that
tells you hey there's a problem
imagine the same thing only in in our
world with code and kubernetes
and the interesting part is that when we
started
we started the company as a top-down
organization
sales led and now after the caveat year
we've actually
made a a huge change and we're now a
product led growth company
and we focus on bottoms up and there is
no more schedule a demo there is only
get started and you get to experience
and evaluate the product
by yourself but you're skipping the
whole fun part here i want to know the
shimon journey because you're sitting
there
and you shared with me before we started
that it was almost a moment a eureka
moment as an entrepreneur that i think
is
so lacking from what we hear today about
entrepreneurial stories this overnight
success which doesn't exist
well now you mentioned that within a
month you already have you know over a
dozen companies subscribed to this new
product
well it's not an overnight success
because we've had a year and a half of
the journey together
i want to know about that journey so it
was very
very strange to me because when i back
in the day when i was an engineering
manager i would never click on book a
demo
i'd rather jump off a cliff then click
on book a demo
why am i crazy like in engineering you
go you test the things out if it works
you put the credit card and
if you need to talk to sales you talk to
them but it works the other way around
and when we started the company this was
the
intuitive thing for me to do but it was
in 2017
everywhere i looked around every vc i
talked to
most of the entrepreneurs and by the way
israel
is very much influenced by the
top-down security oriented companies
which the default playbook is the
security enterprise sales
selling to the cso so everyone i talked
to it was like okay how many companies
did you meet how many dinners did you
have
how many pocs did you start and it was
it was all you know everyone was talking
in top down
um terms and i was like
am i the only crazy one here like and i
was like i must be crazy because
everyone that i was talking to is just
okay get get sdrs
call to people email people go to
dinners and so on
and we've always wanted to do a
self-serve platform a true plg
but but we've always said like in the in
the future in the future in the future
and then what happened is as covid
started we already had more than 15 to
15 companies as customers paying
hundreds of thousands of dollars
in the biggest organizations in the
world yes and they
and at this point we couldn't meet them
anymore
everything became zoom and you couldn't
go to conferences
you know just before that in reinvent we
had 90 demos in four days
it was crazy it was really i wrote a
blog post about it we can link to it
it was totally crazy and then in one
second everything turned
and and i found myself thinking how are
we supposed to continue driving the
business
if we can't meet customers if we can't
present it
at it you know shows because this was
our main mo
and then one day i was sitting in my
home drinking
a glass of a fine liquor and looking at
the website and seeing
the book a demo button i was thinking to
myself
i would never click this button
i would never book a demo to my own
company
why would i do this i would never buy
something like that
and then i knew something had to be done
and me and er we talked about it
and we discovered this wonderful thing
called product led growth
now and i was reading through it and i
was like oh my god this is how i was
always buying software
this is how i want to sell software this
is actually how
i want to go and solve the problem that
i felt in the way that i would want to
buy this solution and this prompted us
to make a huge change
close the us office go back to israel
make a lot of changes and work on
reducing friction and launching as
product led growth and now you're saying
this whole you know
in three sentences you're skipping over
you know weeks and months of labor and
i'm
guessing as an entrepreneur it's not
that easy to just close the u.s branch
for an israeli startup
to open the u.s branch it's a big
milestone also for the vcs it's a big
it's a big vote of confidence that we're
progressing forward and you almost have
to counter intuitively
you know put your ego aside and say no
no we need to go a few steps back so
that we can run much faster forward
you're absolutely right and you know i i
lived in tel aviv for 10 years as a
television
and i really love tel aviv and i did not
want to move to san francisco but i was
like okay
this is the company this is the move
this is the classical top
down the ceo relocates to the valley
opens up a sales office sdrs and so on
and this is what we did
and then as i got there and we actually
opened the office and hired people and
so on and covered hit
actually we're fortunate that we have
great great investors like rona segev
and your father
and ival cohen and many many others and
angels
and they all immediately told me shimon
just come back
we want you to be safe this is what's
important now like no
i want a mission here i moved here
because we need to do this this is what
we're going to do
and i was very stubborn and then i found
myself
months after month after month sitting
in my apartment looking like this and
like doing zoom calls
and like not meeting anyone not talking
at any conferences
and then after some time i was like okay
i'm going to
fly back to israel because there's
nothing for me to do here
and we fired our wonderful salesperson
who now works at another company and
he's amazing
and we changed our marketing to someone
who has more
experience in this bottom-up sales and
bottom-up motion
and we're really really fortunate that
our investment team and leadership
team was really supportive of us and
i met many people who looked at me and
told me you did what
are you crazy and
we just couldn't not not do it this was
like
we felt it that this is the right way
for us to do it
in most companies they do growth motions
and then they add sales on it
so we've already proven that people want
to pay money for it
they need it there is a need and now
we're working on the adoption effort
and a month ago we launched an open
source
go go project that you can actually run
on your laptop and put in your ci cd
and every time that the developer makes
that change
in helm or kubernetes configuration
that the three cli runs and scans for
misconfigurations
and those misconfigurations are central
are managed in a centralized way
through the three dashboard and then you
can also
mix and match and adjust the policy
according to your organizational
standards
and it's it's really wonderful because
you know after one month that we've
launched we have dozens of companies
and i'm just thinking you know in a
top-down world getting dozens of
companies it's like sending
500 emails and cold calling and here you
get people from the internet
they just come in and and you work
really on
on crystallizing the journey and
understanding the pain point and we had
to remove a lot of features from
our product in order to make it really
really
clear as to what is the value that they
are getting
and at this point you see people that
come in
go to the marketing website go to the
docs install it in their computer
play with it put it in their production
apply to their cicd processes and and
it's amazing
and then we we talked to them and we're
like hey i would love to talk to you and
they sent scrolls of feedback
this is great it's good this is awful
please fix this those are the problems
like
amazing now we have real user feedback
that we can use in order to improve our
product
right so you you can literally wake up
in the morning and all of a sudden you
see you have
two new companies that have that you're
on board today this is what happened
today
amazing so tell me a little bit more
about product-led growth so as the ceo
now
you're leading this ship and how are you
thinking about this product
you know as a sort of derivative of what
of the responses from the market
and from the from the developers outside
how how does your mind wrap around
around this
so i think that um the key aspects of
looking at the plg
is understanding the shift from the era
where we used to sell software to the
cio
or the cso then the next shift after it
was
selling the software to the executives
and now here comes the end user era
which is the plg era you're used to
using instagram
you're quite uh influencer there and the
all different apps and you used to a
certain experience and then you come and
you use classical
enterprise software and you go like oh
my god what is this
awful bad ui bed ux doesn't work well
and also
like what is this and and the shift in
plg
is that you cater the product to the end
user
not to the buyer not to the executive
not to the company
to the user great examples of it slack
great examples of it a twilio you
you want to send sms you go and it is
catered
for the engineer to actually send the
messages
and when you think about
working as plg and as a company that
made the transition
from a sales driven organization to plg
you need to change the way of thinking
from there's a customer
and they want feature abc in order to
close the deal
it's the other way around we see x
amount of companies
we think that we can do this feature
according to this
their feedback and this will reduce the
friction and
you have to constantly reduce the
friction
and be data-driven i was just about to
say it sounds like this approach is much
more of a data-driven approach
it's much less subjective to your sales
ability or to the vibe that
the other person got because you're then
you're here you're selling a value and
if you're go you're gonna sell it
because they're coming to you and the
other way around there's a lot of
different factors that may go into them
buying it
and you never really know whether it's
whether you're actually providing real
value right
absolutely you know when you're in a
top-down organization and by the way i'm
not saying that everyone should just do
plg
and there are no companies that need to
do sales approach
[Applause]
so of course if it suits your
your product and you need to and the
product has to
to cater to a very fast self
ability to evaluate the product and if
it brings value to you
it has to show you the aha moment really
really fast
and for you to understand it and if this
this fits your your um
your products category then you can do
it
[Music]
and i think that one of the most
important things is to measure
because as you said it's not like in
top-down organization where oh we had
three dinners i guess it's 50
but here we actually know how many
people come to the website how many
people come to the docks how many people
install it how many people use it
how many invocations they do every day
every week every month
and then we sit as a leadership team and
we look at it we go like okay
where do we think we should optimize now
this area
this area this area and what do we think
has to be done
in order to perform those optimizations
and by the way i gotta say
from my my experience for example our
engineering team
all of a sudden they're really involved
in the business because they see the
numbers
they see the data they see the influence
of releasing new features
fixing bugs and seeing the numbers go up
and understanding exactly their impact
i can imagine the you know the front-end
engineer coming in saying that there's
this drop in conversion between page two
and three
and i can i can see them you know
staying up at night thinking why why is
this happening maybe if i shift this
around or if i play this experiment
it's going to shift and and i just love
this approach completely and it's
you know it's almost like mixing
together a b2c
in a b2b world and and it's such a big
mishmash i think
i think it's amazing shimon we can go on
for hours talking about a product like
growth but i have a few questions for
shimon
and 20 minutes is not enough time nearly
and i want to take it back to your
childhood
what fascinated you truly and it can't
be kubernetes i already did this joke
before and he cracked it up so he
cracked up
completely but what fascinated you as a
kid really
i think that what fascinated me as a kid
and it still fascinated
fascinates me today is understanding how
things work
and this i remember like when i was in
fourth grade i saw my first computer
that my parents brought and i remember
seeing it and i was supposed to be
asleep and then when they went to sleep
i woke up and i and i and i looked at it
and i started clicking all the buttons
and opening it up and looking what's
actually inside what is this thing
literally opening it literally yeah yeah
literally not not turning it on opening
it up
yeah it's like what is here most people
don't do that
for me it was natural you know and and
this fascinates me
how to understand how things work and
and it's i guess it's curiosity in a way
because i'm very very curious
and and this leads you to also
understanding how things work and then
applying it in order to achieve
greater goals for yourself so amazing
along your journey
some role model and a figure of
inspiration for you either
professionally or personally so you know
what i think that
what i take with me almost every day i
would actually say
the founders of iron source really and
there are nine of them
which is a lot and everyone has their
own flavor but
to me i would really really like would
like to have a culture that is similar
to it
they have radical trust they really
really trust in you the first day they
give you the keys
you also get the responsibility but you
get all the credit and to do amazing
things
for me iron source was the land of
opportunity from a developer to a team
leader to an r d manager to a general
manager of an in
of a division and really to grow up
and and for me i always try to enable
every person in the company and to never
say no
in a way like you want to try something
you want to do it you want to achieve it
you should do it and this is the spirit
that i got from it and they really
inspired me when opening this company
amazing amazing and what are three words
or two or four that you would choose to
describe yourself
so i think i'm very very curious i think
that i'm
a very ambitious at it achieving the
things that i really strive to get
which by the way can also make you a bit
tunnel vision
which is not always so good um
and i really really believe in karma i
don't know if it fits in there
but really i really believe in you know
meeting with young entrepreneurs and
helping them like like people helped me
and and always you know meeting great
people
and trying to to help without any you
know at the end of the day
things will turn out good and i really
really believe in good energy and karma
shimon
you